he will not have died in vain but we
cannot allow the righteous cries and
peaceful protesters to be drown out by
an angry mob the biggest victims of the
rioting are peace-loving citizens in our
poorest communities and as their
president I will fight to keep them safe
I will fight to protect you
I am your president of law and order and
an ally of all peaceful protesters but
in recent days our nation has been
gripped by professional anarchists
violent mobs arsonists looters criminals
riders and Tifa and others a number of
state and local governments have failed
to take necessary action to safeguard
their residents innocent people have
been savagely beaten like the young man
in Dallas Texas who was left dying on
the street or the woman in upstate New
York viciously attacked by dangerous
thugs small business owners have seen
their dreams
utterly destroyed New York's finest have
been hit in the face with bricks braved
nurses who have battled the virus are
afraid to leave their homes a police
precinct has been overrun here in the
nation's capital the Lincoln Memorial
and the World War Two memorial have been
vandalized one of our most historic
churches was set ablaze a federal
officer in California an African
American enforcement hero was shot and
killed these are not acts of peaceful
protests these are acts of domestic
terror the destruction of innocent life
and the spilling of innocent blood is an
offense to humanity and a crime against
God America needs creation not
destruction cooperation not contempt
security
not Anarchy healing not hatred justice
not chaos this is our mission and we
will succeed 100% we will succeed our
country always wins
that is why I am taking immediate
presidential action to stop the violence
and restore security and safety in
America by immobilizing all available
federal resources civilian and military
to stop the rioting and looting to end
the destruction and arson and to protect
the rights of law-abiding Americans
including your second Amendment rights
therefore the following measures are
going into effect immediately
first we are ending the riots and
lawlessness that has spread throughout
our country we will end it now today I
have strongly recommended to every
governor to deploy the National Guard in
sufficient numbers that we dominate the
streets mayors and governors must
establish an overwhelming law
enforcement presence until the violence
has been quelled if a city or state
refuses to take the actions that are
necessary to defend the life and
property of their residents
then I will deploy the United States
military and quickly solve the problem
for them I am also taking swift and
decisive action to protect our great
capital Washington DC what happened in
this city last night was a total
disgrace as we speak I am dispatching
thousands and thousands of heavily armed
soldiers military personnel and law
enforcement officers to stop the rioting
looting vandalism assaults and the
wanton destruction of property we are
putting everybody on warning or 7
o'clock curfew will be strict
enforced those who threaten innocent
life and property will be arrested
detained and prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law
I want the organizers of this terror to
be on notice that you will face severe
criminal penalties and lengthy sentences
in jail this includes an Tifa and others
who are leading instigators of this
violence one law and order and that is
what it is one law we have one beautiful
law and once that is restored and fully
restored we will help you we will help
your business and we will help your
family America is founded upon the rule
of law it is the foundation of our
prosperity our freedom and our very way
of life but where there is no law if
there is no opportunity where there is
no justice there is no Liberty where
there is no safety there is no future we
must never give in to anger or hatred
if malice or violence reigns then none
of us is free I take these actions today
with firm resolve and with a true and
passionate love for our country by far
our greatest days lie ahead thank you
very much and now I'm going to pay my
respects to a very very special place
thank you very much